-The movie's received
a lot of critical praise,
which, you know,
anytime anyone's involved
in a film, must be really nice
But I would imagine, for you
for Rod, feedback you received
from not only those
who served there
but people, in general,
who served
and Gold Star families
and anyone who has, you know
lost someone
who has served in the military
how important was it to ge
positive feedback from them,
and have you found that that's
what you've received so far?
-Yeah, I mean, almost entirely
I mean, obviously, you know,
thousands of people
served there.
Love people who served there
et cetera.
So you're never gonna get 100%
but it's funny.
Yes, the reviews
have been great,
and there's a really positiv
Rotten Tomatoes score,
which I'm learning
for the first time what that is.
It's like 93%.
It's fresh.
-They don't have that
for CNN shows, Rotten Tomatoes
Is that not...
-I'm pretty sure I would b
certified fresh, but they don'
do it for news shows.
But at the 10-year anniversary
of the big attack,
so, last October,
General John Allen,
who was the commander
of U.S. and allied forces
in Afghanistan, who now holds --
heads up a think tank,
he and Millennium Films,
who made the movie,
hosted an event in D.C.
to show the film,
which was not 100% done,
but close to it,
to veterans and their families
and Gold Star families.
And we were really nervous
Rod and I,
because I can't imagine
serving there,
I can't imagine
losing a loved one there,
much less then going to se
your lost loved one
portrayed by Orlando Bloom
or whoever,
Milo Gibson, whatever,
and then see their death
portrayed on screen.
So we were
really, really nervous,
and it was
a very intense experience.
We had
some grief counselors there,
just in case anybody
needed to talk.
There was one soldier that lef
like in the first five minutes
just because it was too intense,
'cause it just re-created
the experience he had
of flying into this camp
in the dead of night
and then waking up the next da
and you see the mountains
that you're surrounded by.
It was just too much for him
Understandable.
You know, I don't think
I could watch such a thing
But then after the film --
It was nerve-racking.
We went around
one by one by one.
And to a person, they said
that they thought the film
honored their loved one,
and they felt, you know,
as positive as one could fee
about such a thing,
which has just been great.
And, you know,
there were a couple
liberties that were taken
in the film.
People who served in 2006
were put with the unit in 2009
so as to tell his story,
as well, et cetera,
but generally speaking,
it's pretty factual.
So, yeah, after that,
I was like, "Okay.
Anything after this now is gravy
because these are the people
I care about the most,
what they think."
-You know, the book is great
and the film has turned ou
wonderfully well, too.
I want to ask about this
before I let you go.
You know, we are coming up -
You probably tuned into this -
on an election.
And let's assume
you and you're colleagues
will be working the election
desk on election night.
It came up
in that interview last night
this is likely
because of the fact
that there's gonna be more
vote-by-mail,
this is likely an election
that won't be called
in the same way that previou
elections have been called
How do you prepare
for a night like that?
I know it's 90-plus days out
but are you already
thinking about that?
-Yeah, I am.
One of the things to think about
is just how many of those Hous
seats we didn't find out about
in the 2018 election
until a week later.
And while it was clear
the Democrats
were gonna take the House,
it wasn't clear
what the margin was going to be.
And a lot of them
were on the West Coast,
where they have vote-by-mail
and there was an extensive
counting system,
and I think one of the thing
that we need to do in the media,
in the news media,
is make sure that voters are
prepared for what might end up
not being a clear winner
on election night.
Now, on the other hand,
there could be one.
[ Dogs barking ]
I mean, if President -- sorry.
Sorry about the dogs.
-It should be -- It should be --
for our viewers to know,
Jake's dog is a huge
Donald Trump supporter.
[ Both laugh ]
Anytime Jake talks about him..
-He's yelling -- he's barkin
like -- it's very rude.
Thanks for letting the dogs out.
So, anyway, they had been told
I was doing the show,
just so you know.
-Sure, of course, of course.
-I assume that you are
in the position
on the family totem pole
where I am,
which is not at the top.
-No, no, no.
I assumed I was above dog,
but I guess we're...
[ Both laugh ]
-No one is above dogs
in this house.
Anyway, I think people
just need to be prepared.
I mean,
it could be that we know,
if it's a landslide for Bide
or for Trump, you know?
If all of the battleground
states are called,
if we know that Pennsylvania
Michigan, and Wisconsin
go one way or the other,
that will certainly --
I mean, nobody expects
Donald Trump
to win California, right?
Or Joe Biden to win Texas.
But that said, people need
to just understand
that it might
take a little while.
-Do you think the Presiden
comprehends or understands that?
-I can't really speak
for what the President
comprehends or understands
Right now, I'm just focusing
my hope and desire that he
understands and comprehend
what needs to be done
to contain this pandemic
because that remains, to me,
at least, it seems,
and every health expert
I interview,
out of range for him as of now
in terms
of what needs to be done.
So, in terms of electoral math
no, I don't think he gets it
No.
-No, I think that's probably
a safe bet.
Hey, it was always -- it i
always great to talk to you.
Hopefully, you know, again
it would be the first time
that in the period
between your visits,
things get better, but I reall
do hope that that is the case,
and I look forward
to seeing you then,
hopefully maybe one more tim
before the election.
-Any time you want, and --
although, like I said,
as soon as you turn off
this button,
as soon as your staff
clicks the Zoom,
something gets set into
the universe and there's bad..
-That's true.
-...bad juju,
and something --
like, a comet Is about to hit.
Like, we already have a plague
and unrest
and all sort of other things
so I don't know
what could come next.
-I think, if anything, we should
just apologize in advance
to everyone
before we say goodbye.
-Yes, remember the good old days
of the plague.
That's what we will be saying.
-Yep.
Be well, love to your family
See you next time.
-All right, buddy.
Love to your family, as well